Gustav “s4” Magnusson was born on  April 1, 1992 in Sweden.
As the youngest, s4 was often left to watch his three older brothers play video games.
But while he was watching, s4 developed a
different kind of appreciation for the games
his brothers played.
He was watching from the outside, analysing how they played so that when he finally got his turn,
he was ahead of the curve.
But as he grew older, S4's family came to realize that his dedication to games
wasn't different than other kids dedication to sports.
But it was in Heroes of Newerth where s4 first made a name for himself.
(Casting)
Alongside a slew of other future Dota 2 stars.
He signed with Lions eSports Klubb and made
it all the way to the NASL Season 2 Finals,
but couldn’t attend due to visa issues.
Just a few months later, s4 switched to Dota 2, and joined Team Empire during a period
of roster instability.
Only months after joining, s4 left Empire
to form a new team, The Tough Bananas,
which was quickly signed
by the Copenhagen Wolves.
(Casting)
But that roster didn’t find much success
either, leaving s4 to find yet another new team.
This time, he formed No Tidehunter alongside Admiral Bulldog, Eternal Envy, Black and Kizzles.
After some success, Black and Kizzle left
the team, and were replaced by Loda and Akke.
s4 didn’t know it at the time, but he was
finally on a team that was set to make history.
(Casting)
At DreamHack Winter 2012, No Tidehunter didn’t drop a match in the group stage, and beat
Evil Geniuses 2-1 in the grand finals thanks in part to an unbelievable strategy concocted by s4 himself.
(Casting)
The now-iconic Roshan Bait single-handedly made s4 the captain of No Tidehunter,
"How did you pitch that to your teammates, like 'hey guys we're gonna do this crazy strat that requires one of us
to die.' at the very beginning."
"So what happened is, we played the Grand Finals not on the main stage in game one.
and then game two we had to go out to the main stage.
But we had like a 30 minute break.
So it was like, what are we gonna do guys? We're down one game, we're playing against EG.
So yeah we just came up with a strat to get some momentum you know into the game."
"So, you actually came up with that strat on the spot."
"Yeah."
"You didn't see it was a pub strat or anything like that?"
"No we were actually, to start off trying to do a level one rush. But then, we came up with better ideas
as we went on."
But it wasn't the only thing about that tournament that propelled him into stardom.
S4 was pioneering strategy and No Tidehunter were just outplaying their opponents.
(Casting)
No Tidehunter took a Christmas break, but s4 kept playing.
He participated in Beyond the Summit’s Fistful of Tangoes 1v1 tournament.
"Good evening ladies and gentlemen, boys and girls, it is time for something completely different."
"That's right, we are going to try our hands at our first ever 1v1 tournament."
"It's called a Fistful of Tangoes, if you don't get the reference I suggest you do some googling."
He placed second, after a long loser’s bracket run where he beat KuroKy, Korok, SingSing and Synderen,
cementing his place as one of Dota 2’s best young talents.
(Casting)
Once the tournament circuit restarted, No Tidehunter continued to do well,
winning StarLadder StarSeries Season 5 in April.
(Casting)
Just after that, No Tidehunter was signed to Alliance, and the team went on an absolute tear.
The team looked unstoppable.
(Casting)
And they were.
"Good to have this much momentum, or are you guys like man maybe we're peaking very early,
when it comes to this kind of thing."
"I think it's good.
If you imagine being like a losing team, I don't think that would be feeling so good
going into another tournament."
"It's a good problem to have I guess."
"Yeah,
Alliance went 14-0 in TI3’s group stage.
"Alliance, the team from Sweden. Undefeated in the prelims."
then moved on to drop just one game in the upper bracket.
"Like, I always imagined how, it would be for the players in the games, what's the pressure and stuff like that."
"But now, getting to TI3, it's amazing."
But Natus Vincere put together an impressive run of their own
and were slated to face off against Alliance in the grand finals.
"Ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Grand Finals of The International 3.
(Cheering)
In game one, Na'Vi's Puppey brought out several unique picks.
But S4 stuck to the usual gameplan. And they ended up stomping Na'Vi.
(Casting)
The challenge was met with force, as Na'Vi took a quick game of their own.
Despite the close series, Na'Vi put Dendi on Io in the mid lane for game three.
(Casting)
Thanks to the pick. Na'Vi had control of the early game.
And Alliance were firmly shut down.
(Casting)
With that Na'Vi were just one game away from winning TI3.
And the chance for the majority of the roster, to carve their names on the  Aegis of Champions twice.
Both teams opened game four with stable, well-rounded picks.
But S4's ace came in the final pick with Night Stalker.
(Casting)
With Alliance tying up the series 2-2, TI3 already broke new ground for a TI Grand Final.
"This is the first time in TI history that we're going to a game number five."
Creative drafts and ballsy plays characterized the series, but the best was yet to come.
"It all comes down to this, one more game, $2 million dollars on the table."
(Casting)
Alliance took the first Aegis at 21 minutes and stalled the game. Waiting for Roshan to reset.
As Game 5 neared it’s end S4 showed up when it counted most and delivered a clutch Dream Coil, giving Alliance the chance to close it out.
(Casting)
S4 stood at the very peak of Dota.
He was a key player in the most important game ever played.
(Casting)
He was the man behind the million dollar dream coils.
After TI3, teams started to catch up to Alliance.
Na`Vi got their revenge on Alliance in a 3-1 grand finals at StarLadder Season 7.
(Casting)
Alliance then fell out of MLG Columbus in the group stage, and the team only managed to pick up two LAN wins between TI3 and TI4.
They weren’t a terrible team, but they were a shell of their former selves.
"Welcome to The International."
S4 won the 1v1 tournament at TI4, but it was the only victory he’d taste all tournament.
(Casting)
Alliance went 6-9 in the group stage, tied for 11th.
In the span of one year, Alliance went from unstoppable world champions to also-rans.
S4 decided to try his luck elsewhere.
He teamed up with his longtime rival, legendary Na`Vi captain Puppey to help found Team Secret, alongside Fly, BigDaddyN0tail and Kuroky.
On the surface, Secret looked like a dream team. Every player on the team was one of the best in their position.
However, in there debut at Starladder Season 10 they would get stomped by none other than s4’s former team, Alliance.
(Casting)
Eventually finding their footing, Team Secret would go on to close out the calendar year by placing 3rd/4th at ESL One New York, 2nd at StarLadder Season 10, 3rd at the Summit 2, 1st at XMG Captain’s Draft and 1st at Dota Pit League Season 2.
Over the holiday season, the team lost Fly and N0tail but replaced them with Arteezy and Zai, maintaining their status as a super team.
(Casting)
Simply put, Secret were incredible, winning trophy after trophy in the lead-up to TI5.
But it all fell apart at Ti.
(Casting)
Secret placed second in their group with a 4-3-0 record, but fell in the bracket, losing 2-0 to EHOME and 2-1 to Virtus.pro.
For all his hard work, S4 had another mediocre TI performance on his record. It wasn’t terrible, but it wasn’t a win.
(Casting)
Team Secret collapsed after the loss. Puppey was the only player who stuck with the org, and rebuilt its roster by himself.
For his part, s4 went back to Alliance and over the course of the year, they rebuilt their TI3-winning squad.
The team failed to put together any significant wins after TI, but in December, they picked up a massive win at World Cyber Arena 2015.
(Casting)
And just a few weeks later, at StarLadder i-League Season 1, the old Alliance swept TI5 champions Evil Geniuses in the finals to take first place.
Things starting looking up for the old heroes. But the nostalgic wave didn’t last long.
Alliance didn’t find any more wins that year. They attended every Valve Major, and qualified for TI6, but were swept out of the bracket stage by EHOME and Fnatic.
(Casting)
While S4 was struggling, some of his old Secret teammates had formed OG.
s4 joined, reuniting with Fly and N0tail, and switched to the offlane.
(Casting)
OG looked good as the season started, but they came into their own at the Boston Major, where s4 won his first ever Valve Major.
For s4, a player who seemed past his prime, OG represented a shot at redemption.
(Casting)
And OG kept up their momentum by taking first place at the Kiev Major.
S4 found redemption on OG. He found a team that was what Secret was supposed to be.
(Casting)
OG placed 7th-8th at TI that year, and while they’ve looked strong since, the team isn’t favored to win TI8.
But in Dota 2, TI is just about the only tournament that matters.
There are important events outside of TI, but none can match its prestige.
None have its multi-million dollar prize pool.
None can award you the Aegis, and title of best in the world. And S4 wanted to be known as the best.
He knows what it means, what it feels like to stand at the top. And he won't rest until he feels it again.